hi everybody how's it goin my name is
Suzanne brillante AKA san francisco
pianist and chanteuse kitten on the keys
bye everybody
and i where there's so many of you it's
kind of bustling in here tonight
okay um at the long now foundation
contacted me and invited me to play some
historical San Francisco songs I'm like
that sounds like an awful lot of fun if
you know the words you can sing along
with me now this first one is about the
prettiest girl that the miners loved
[Music]
I love a good song about spelunking here
we go
in Cup and canyon excavating for a mine
dwelt a miner a 49er and his pretty
daughter Clementine light she was like a
fairy and her shoes for number nine
Haring minors without topsis Santa's
were for Clementine if you know the
words it goes oh you were lost and gone
forever dreadful sorry Clementine guess
what else she did drove the duck blaze
to the water every morning just at night
hit her foot against the splinter fell
into the foamy brine it doesn't sound
too much fun but one more time
Oh m'darlin dreadful sorry Clementine
thank you you all have lovely voices now
are you ready to sweat to the oldies
folks now this next song I swear we're
just gonna party like it's 19 29 this is
a little bit a mixture of the Castro
Street Fair [ __ ] Shack Folsom Street
Fair and the Barbary Coast this is a
song called masculine women feminine men
from 1925
hey hey we're gonna going night to day
hey hey fellers are just as bad I'll say
go anywhere just stand and stare you
think they're mad when you look at the
clothes that they wear shocking
masculine women feminine men which is
the rooster which is the hen it's hard
telepods today and say sister is busy
learning to shave brother just loves a
permanent wave it's hard to tell the
punch of day hey girls were girls and
boys were boys when I wasn't talked but
now we don't know who was who were
what's even what knickers and trousers
baggy and wide nobody knows he's walking
inside those masculine women and
feminine men
aunt is busy rolling her own uncle is
always fine clone it's hard to tell the
punches day hey hey
you go in to give your girl a kiss in
the hall but instead you find you're
kissing her brother Paul Moss got a
sweater up to her chin path got a girdle
holding them in those masculine women
and feminine man
[Applause]
well this is awful awful fun I was like
hmmm historical San Francisco songs do
they want me to play Journey sorry so
let's finish with that fabulous
quintessential song ain't no Jeanette
MacDonald but perhaps you can be out
there for me
[Music]
it only takes a Connie corner of this
great big world to make a place that you
love
my home upon the hill I find I love you
still I've been away but now I'm back to
tell you San Francisco open your Golden
Gate don't let no strangers wait outside
your door of San Francisco here is your
wandering one say that a wonder no more
other places only make you lovely facets
tell me you're the heart of the gold Dan
west okay everybody you can sing with me
at this last part the words are really
easy it's San Francisco I'll never go
home I'll go me
[Music]
thank you for having me and I hope you
do please welcome to the stage mr.
Stuart brand
[Applause]
well this is I'm a steward bran from the
long now foundation this is a testimony
to some kind of a fear that people have
with time let's get a audience like this
you just look at old movies
our akai Vil interest is actually
interested in the future and nobody's
better at that than Ric Bellinger so
let's join him in the past and the
future right
thank you thank you your applause is
totally premature of course you haven't
seen the film yet but um welcome to Lost
landscapes for thanks so much for coming
there's a whole lot to do tonight so I'm
gonna save the big ideas for the Q&A
period after the film the film itself is
gonna be about 70 minutes long and for
those of you who are regulars there's
about 30 new segments so after that
we'll have Q&A and then we'll hang out
in the lobby so this is not your
ordinary movie screening I'm not that
much of a film buff and we're not going
to be watching clips from vertigo bullet
or dark passage although sorry but it is
now clear of course we could make an
awesome lost landscape show out of
streets of San Francisco maybe one day
we'll do that but instead tonight's show
is made out of home movies industrial
films outtakes piece of newsreel the odd
bits of moving image that are just
beginning to attract the attention of
scholars and fans most of what we're
gonna see tonight was shot by
individuals we know who a few of them
are and we're gonna talk about that but
most are anonymous some were shot by
tourists and a lot were shot by San
Franciscans themselves but the key thing
is that they were made by amateurs there
are no committees no focus groups behind
any of this material they show daily
life they show work the changing look of
the landscape and quite often you know
the excitement of traveling to San
Francisco and when you begin to put
together a lot of these everyday
quotidian images a different kind of
history I should actually really say
histories begins to emerge it's a
history where ordinary people and
everyday life moves to the center
instead of the fringes and where the
activities of celebrities of governments
and corporations recede into the
background and you know I think this is
where history as a practice is actually
heading in the direction of personal
research and documentation this is a
very uneasy issue for scholars I'm sorry
I don't mean to single you out and it
gets as it gets easier for almost anyone
to be their own historian I think we're
gonna see all kinds of interesting and I
think formative conflicts over validity
and authority and there's also gonna be
another problem which is that we're
gonna have too much documentation in
some areas and far too little of others
we see this in the world of home movies
there's too much fishing you know and
not enough and not enough mission
districts and then we're gonna have to
figure out how to keep digital
information alive which is actually the
least of our problems I think so in fact
most of the film in the show tonight
actually survives by accident Industrial
and sponsored films were made for
specific reasons at specific times and
home movies were of course made to be
shown within individual families not
necessarily for posterity so while this
is a feel-good show about the city we
know and love I'd also like to challenge
you to think about how history is
changing and how all of us can become
better historians you can ask questions
about that and I want to welcome all of
you who are coming for the first time
and I apologize that it's been so hard
to get into these shows and if you have
friends who couldn't get in tonight
please tell them that we'll do a repeat
in 2010 and if they sign up in the book
outside at the long now table I'll send
them an email and also for the first
time on December 16th I'm going to do
lost landscapes of the East Bay at
counter pulse counter pulse in ninth and
mission of course we're premiering it in
San Francisco but
what the hey and I would also like to
invite all of you to come and visit the
library that Megan and I run at eighth
and Folsom you can read about it online
it's a source for hit mostly historical
images and texts and it's a great place
to get lost so a few people that I'd
very much like to thank first I'm really
grateful to the G family for making
their home movies available to me for
this event these are especially exciting
to us because their houses across the
street from ours and we'll see our block
in the 50s and 60s
Kathy G and for members of her family
are here this evening and they might
have time to stay around and answer any
of your questions if you have any and
I'm also extremely grateful to our
commentators who have mics and they're
going to give us some pithy
identifications and maybe some sound
bikes each of them knows the city from a
different angle so great Brecon is a
historical geographer and the author of
the absolutely essential book the one
book you should read know one of two
books you should read about San
Francisco history Imperial San Francisco
urban power and earthly ruin and he
founded California's living New Deal
project which is both an inventory of
existing New Deal project construction
and residue that still survives plus an
attempt to contextualize it in the
culture at Holmes who was a longtime
member of San Francisco's ah insurgent
creative community has performed with
the San Francisco mime troupe since 1973
and has instigated and led the st.
stupids Day Parade
since the late 1970s Thank You Edie and
woody Labonte founded a western
neighborhoods project which focuses on
the history of San Francisco's outside
lands and just published Carville by the
sea which is about an astonishing
episode that happened in the 1890s when
San Francisco transit operators sold
surplus cable cars and horse cars to the
public who repurposed them as bars
restaurants studios houseboats and a
bohemian settlement on the beach it's an
amazing book and you can see him
afterwards and find out how to get a
copy now we have expert common
but you are the soundtrack this by the
way is you if if you know what you're
seeing shout it out if you want to know
shout out a question if and feel free to
comment remember there's a little bit of
sound in the show
but a lot of the show is silent and you
have to fill the gap there's not going
to be any waves of music to wash over
you and put you to sleep and I end with
my pitch this is it we need film if you
have any historical footage of the Bay
Area did your family shoot home movies
did your friends if so I'd really like
to hear from you I spend far too much
time each year looking for film for this
show and I know there's a great deal
more out there so I would love your help
and that's what I've got and and on with
the show thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Golden Gate City figured out an
up-to-date way to send its readings to
the world by way of the sky in letters
ten feet high a new idea that just as
bright and cheerful as San Francisco
itself the autogyros piloted by captain
Claude Owen and the captain's taking an
awful chance in that crowd of building
one little slip and the greetings will
turn into something not quite so
cheerful he's aiming for the beautiful
Civic Center and he's only got a space
to land in a hundred and twenty-five
feet by 300 with a trolley line of the
upper edge but the captain knows his
ducking and for the first time in
history a plane lands on San Francisco's
front walk well it's a ninth thought San
Francisco and the same to you and many
oh that was the library building back
there the old library maybe know where
this is
so this is a shot in 1941 by John
summers we've used a little bit of his
film before he shot a comprehensive and
somewhat jittery view of most of San
Francisco Treasure Island he's operating
an electronic device under one 10,000
feet was 2 o'clock in the afternoon well
you seem to be in the left seat when
he's back
I want my wife to see this
that's SFO it's a WPA project dc-3
they're so
and it's still 2 that's 19 that's from
1938 this is about 62 or 63 is this
before candlestick got enclosed
go left go left both ways in the top
there way lower high-rise this is just
before the the high-rise boom this is
about 64 65 I believe interesting it's
gotta be late 50s right I stand
corrected
transportation to San Francisco was by
ferry a convivial mode of travel that
particularly in the evening had elements
of fantasy and generated a sense of
adventure that even the meat could enjoy
many a commuter dreamed secret dreams
from the blown spray wet his cheeks and
his sole sword to the undulation of
these crimes in the Bay Area I know
that's interesting that s-curve
this is a too short excerpt too huge
shield powers rose like madly after
years of planning the visuals and
blueprints of the engineers took
physical shape under the skilled hands
of the men of action
the Frenchman long experienced in this
hazardous business when about their work
sometimes in precarious positions
expertly guiding the steel into place
some sections wait as much as 79 pounds
[Music]
that American Bridge company's plan that
Gary Indiana and Ambridge Pennsylvania
whoops he's stuck
[Music]
[Music]
so right they're wearing helmets
[Music]
on the tower 500 feet above the water
Bridgman adjust them secure the wire
rope
[Music]
to provide a firm safe footing for the
Bridgman a special type of catwalk was
designed USS Cyclones chain-link fence
was chosen for slight weight low wind
resistance and great strength this
bundle of cyclone fence will cover a
distance of 100 feet
[Music]
when sufficient flooring had been placed
to reach the next tower
it was stretched into position this job
calls for iron nerves for the Frenchmen
ride the catwalk
during the stretching operation but
after the precarious footing during
power erection this template catwalk
would be fixed hello oh sure leave them
fun but with a serious purpose to keep
the wire mesh sliding freely as it is
stretched over the steel rope San
Francisco Bay looked like this from the
catwalk far below the old ferryboat
plows solidly along soon to be replaced
by trains of electric cars automobiles
and trucks rolling in an endless stream
across the bridge that soars above at
dinnertime the Bridgman lose no time
hitting for home run along the catwalk
to whet the appetite then the Sky Ride
and down the escalator helter skelter
[Music]
remember that Unocal Tower I am bring it
back I don't know if any of you saw the
Nixon campaign ad on the side of the
building a minute ago eastbound tolls
thank you something nice going this is
about 1937-38 we want to go in the
carpool lane don't do it
[Laughter]
that's the dog perspective there you go
took talking dog go ahead
there quite a number of these sort of
triumphal movies after the bridge is
open they they everybody shot their trip
across the bridge not many cars it was
expensive the bridge was built with a
second level to accommodate the most
modern into urban trains and operation
anywhere controlled at each end of the
bridge by a tower that houses the
switches relays and circuit but make up
the nerve centers of one of the most
efficient train control systems and
existence with safety devices that are
the product the most modern engineering
genius inside the cab the motor man
controls the speed of his train in
response to the panel which indicates 35
miles an hour at this point this
indicator is part of an elaborate safety
system worked by means of electrical
impulses carried through the rail
if the motorman were to disregard the
speed indicated on the panel control of
the train would be automatically taken
away from him there has never been a
train collision on the bridge since they
began to use it in 1939 the Bell
indicates a change of speed watch
closely you'll see the indicator dropped
at 25 miles an hour if he gets too close
to the preceding train he is
automatically stopped and that's nice to
know in a fog which sometimes creeps in
on the San Francisco side approaching
the terminal where the air is fragrant
with a smell of spice and will keep off
e the speed drops from 17 to 11 miles an
hour
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Transbay terminal interior naturally
love it while it's there this is a 41
and this is 50s we used to have a
freeway in front of our Ferry Building
and I don't know why this footage was
shot but it's really interesting it's
some early South of Market focusing on
transportation this is the state
Beltline Carberry Belt Line Railroad
where are we
2nd 2nd Street
maybe Folsom when Steampunk was real
it's it's even realer now so this is um
I believe the United railroad strike of
1917 this is a piece of news footage I
know nothing about who shot it or about
its origin is this the ironworkers
it's maybe the ironworkers yeah I think
that's the Union Iron Works gallon
patrol got it and then they're but
they're going to have something to do
with the streetcar same year I believe
this is an early version of critical
mass before they invented bicycles do we
know where we are the assembly hall
what number is that car Rick can you
tell not from here yes so I wonder and
maybe when I see it on the big screen I
wonder if the ironworkers and the
railroad strike have been mixed cut
together here are the first pictures of
strike paralyzed San Francisco in the
grip of a general labor tire streets are
deserted as surface cars cease running
and citizens unable to travel remain
indoors only a few automobiles can
operate because most filling stations
have exhausted their supplies and can
obtain no more gasoline motor trucks
stand idle where their drivers left them
very little food is being moved into the
city and with a threat of famine before
them
crowds Jam the markets but supplies
dwindle rapidly and there is no meat to
be had to the possibility of mob
violence is added fear of pestilence
while on every hand those shops give
mute testimony to the disastrous
economic consequence of the strike mayor
Rossi states the position of his
administration I must insist first that
law and order shall prevail
second that those desiring to furnish
the people of San Francisco with the
necessities of life must be permitted to
do so without hindrance
efforts of business interest to forcibly
open the strike paralyzed port of San
Francisco fail open warfare rages
through the streets of the city is 3000
Union picket battle 700 police guns
teargas
clubs and fists bring injuries to more
than 80 persons and caused the death of
two listen to the strikers side of the
story we are asking for a general strike
to keep organized labor on the Pacific
coast we're not only active force but
we're going to get it then with a
general strike and additional violence
threaten 2500 Guardsmen move in
commanded by Colonel Mittal State
National Guard and protecting life and
property this we propose to do at any
cause these idle ships and tears have
more than local significance they are
symbols of wasted millions in represent
a backward step in our recovery program
so that was a that was hysterical
national newsreel footage from the 1934
longshore strike which became a general
strike and this is a parade probably
mostly of members of the ILA under
left-wing rank-and-file leadership along
the Embarcadero it's unusual footage we
don't know exactly who shot at whether
it was the Union whether it was police
whether it was newsreel whether it was
freelance it kind of gets close in some
of those battles were happening right
where the ballpark is today the Jan's
ballpark and on Rincon Hill big the
Battle of Rincon Hill as they called it
July 5 1934
[Applause]
quite quiet day on the yeah thank you
and this is footage of the Barbary Coast
that's 1914 if it's a fragment that's
right
it's like Pacific Street or Jackson or
something
I believe it's Jackson Pacific you're
always wrong Rick hey I just show the
films you will see more women it has as
much to do with the sailors
that was fun but you know I've heard
that before at other screenings and in
the public sphere at a certain point you
see there there are many fewer images of
women navigating the streets in the film
that I've been able to find but I think
we've made up for it in other ways
wait and see that was 1914 1915 this is
the same neighborhood in 1931 these are
amateur films Benga Hyde alright and
this is the same neighborhood and in
decline as you can obviously see
kearney in Pacific
and this is the shrine parade from I
believe 31 or 32 and this is the native
sons and daughters of the Golden West
proposal for the what became quite Tower
and here we begin to G families movies
on a roof in Chinatown around 1945
[Applause]
Auburn alley
this is a standard 8 millimeter film
transferred
alfresco down in a minute you'll see
children that are in the audience
this is probably right after the war
isn't it Kathy I think 46 47 ish
I think this Powell
yay
Playland
the goofy village I said put screams in
your dreams the roller-coaster went down
fifty five I think so it's before that
the shoots was like a waterslide ride
with no seatbelts
I believe this baby's in the audience
tonight and this is now on Union Street
isn't it are you sure the baby survived
and that's a goodbye to Union Street and
hello to the richmond district in 1954
it's the go-go 50s into the fog this is
Cathy G and front is here tonight what
high school Washington go Eagles
it's the the call bulletin paper route
it's not the shopping News
safety patrol and then this is the year
it snowed fifty to sixty two thank you
and this is up on Mira Loma you know by
Portola yeah the Mira Loma lodge is
still there and get a drink and then
this is when our neighborhood was
exciting
[Applause]
still is this is 15th in Balboa I know
[Music]
watch for the very last shot in this
sequence it's kind of funny
and we're looking down what is that
Jones maybe Taylor
I think I'm 0 for 3
this is 1941 hats and gloves and this is
earlier
color film starts to look reliably good
in 37-38 although it goes back much
further
that's the humble bank building
this is 1941 again in the summertime
they had four tracks on Market Street so
it was kind of dangerous to board the
streetcars in the inner side
if you mean the Covarrubias mural I
think it went back to Mexico was from
the Treasure Island Fair this is the
during the transit strike when is that
1949 47 49 when people actually drove in
and parked on market looks like right
they're all a church that's the
Weinstein department stores see that mid
market it needs a lot of work maybe some
billboards you can see the DeYoung
building there on the left before they
put the the steel on it it's just been
restored
at the Gary streetcar coming in and this
is a Charles Lindbergh I don't do this
as a tribute to Charles Lindbergh but
because it shows Market Street in 1927
during his ticker tape parade and again
it's this whole idea that the periphery
of the image is often more interesting
than what you see in the and the
foreground
thank you thank you
it's got a great driver and his
reception at Civic Center Plaza so this
is I showed you a little bit of it last
year this is the part I didn't show you
and we've just done a new print and a
new transfer and it looks quite nice so
this is the one where the same cars and
wagons keep coming in front of the
camera right yes and for a long time it
was thought that this film was produced
in 1905 and then the license plate
collectors were mobilized and they as
usual and they rose to the occasion and
they happen to know that I think that
one that just went by 48 67 wasn't
issued until early 1906 and so they've
been able to date this as early 1906 so
this is a potentially even a few weeks
before the quake the total film is it's
about 11 and a half minutes I think
we're looking at three minutes of it
here and one day one day some way
somehow we'll do a beautiful HD
screening somewhere and I'll let you
guys know
[Applause]
there we go again
[Laughter]
so this is really an argument you know
for that idea that's been gaining belief
gaining credence in Holland and in
Europe that minimal traffic control
causes people to behave sort of survive
ibly what are these guys in the right
smuggling
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this is where he gets run down I mean if
you think that the if you think that the
there's a lack of civility now between
cyclists and pedestrians the issue with
between a horses and horseless carriages
was you know Kahn tested extremely
intensely and often violently in those
days too
each horse could drop ten pounds of
fecal matter on the street every day
just a little side note just like our
governor they made Golden Gate Park
yet one thing that's interesting is this
cable car really doesn't seem to stop
there's there's 48 67 again
stop
I hit you over the head last year with
about eight minutes of post-quake
apocalyptic damage so this year we just
have a few shots which we hadn't seen
before we saw a poor version of one of
them in previous years so this is just a
little bit this is it the obviously the
periphery of the burn zone somewhere
around Van Ness and then this is along
Fillmore you know the new business
district that emerged almost immediately
after the quake what I just love about
this is that you know it's the the
intimacy of it it's a great piece of
actuality footage it doesn't have a
narrative it doesn't have a story which
is why I like it
I think that's Eddie and Fillmore we
looked up the storage company in the
phonebook from that period
and this is the now gone a Fillmore
Street help me it's the counterweighted
cable car line where the weight of one
car helped pull the other up as gravity
thank you
this is shot around 38 39 by a visitor
Fillmore Street
where's the line of tourists
I think tourism was down a little bit
and you know before the World's Fair it
was the depression
it is quite empty
and this is this sum this was these are
outtakes for a film shop for the
Convention & Visitors Bureau
and I just like it because it's like
vertigo on cable cars there's quite a
lot of this I purposely cut it so that
there's no Geographic continuity at all
it's um
I said 63 and then a member of the
audience last year emailed me I think to
say it was 64 so I thank you for that
what about the license plate guys
right where the license plate colectors
when we need them all these cars have
retired and living Havana
aren't you going there next ed
Mormons
[Music]
over the hills and all along the way
we're building a dream for tomorrow
we're building in a dream for tomorrow
we're trained we turn it off a little
bit the land go through the Tom by night
and day and sunshine touches every hand
in parks 69
[Music]
over the hills and all along
we're building a dream for the borrowed
we're building the dream for tomorrow
we're bill
dream or tomorrow it's Bechtel theme
song it's an earworm I warn you along
the way in three counties Bart is
building a high-speed rail Rapid Transit
System planned for your convenience
designed for your comfort and
deliberately aimed at giving you a safer
faster more economical ride than your
automobile fully aware as Lewis Mumford
says that a city exists not for the
constant passage of motorcars but for
the care and culture of men cities will
maintain their character to unscarred by
heavy concrete swaths of freeway
freeways that carry the extravagance of
one car one passenger mostly at a
standstill
instead Bart trains carrying thousands
of comfortably seated passengers will
glide quietly through the bay to under
the Ferry Building and into the Market
Street subway so when you climb across
Market Street or ride a bus that's been
detoured remember that your surface
difficulties are temporary while below
ground here and in the other two urban
core cities Oakland and Berkeley 975
sandhogs are tunneling twenty-one miles
of subway and when it's completed you
and the Bay Area will not only feel
better
you both look better in the fall Street
Station you look something like this
along the way you may stop at a magazine
stand by commute tickets from the
automatic vending machine enjoy the
clean spacious architect-designed
station
Crissy Field 50s not clear this is the
Rancho Hoff family home movies and they
took their employees to the Golden Gate
International Exposition early one
morning and we'll visit with them for a
few minutes so the rental office was a
women's clothing store if you remember
in vertigo he dresses Jimmy Stewart
dresses Kim Novak a transyl Hoffs bed
stores in San Francisco and in Los
Angeles as well
National Cash Register pavilion do they
go to Sally rands yes as a matter of
fact they do it was a still a
family-friendly show however this is
Treasure Island and the Golden Gate
International Exposition 1939-1940 it's
a tower of the Sun the cash register
didn't it count how many people came to
the fair
I believe it showed that attendance
figures yeah had a running total that's
the gay way
step right I was a scientific presence
there
dude they misspelled nude the cowgirls
and Sally rands were these sort of body
stockings that made him appear naked
this is amateur footage of the opening
of the bridge Golden Gate 37
any people in here an 87 when they close
the bridge well you almost broke it you
remember this isn't lakeshore which is a
neighborhood between Ocean Avenue and
slope Boulevard out in the west side of
town your Lake Merced I think this is
1946 everybody has a green strip of lawn
that was before they started painting
the sidewalk green and that's like Stern
Grove in the background there the trees
and this is a golden gate hydrogen
elderly tomatoes and other ancient fruit
grandfather eggs and such the ammunition
for the annual brawl between the frosh
and sophomores at University of San
Francisco
it's a scene of bloodshed and slaughter
a frightful toll of carnage and
destruction so a brave young man is
coming here an unknowing phase now that
might be worse than death itself it
finally finishes in a draw but it'll
never be forgotten the Battle of garbage
hill I think it was like the Masonic
cemetery etre yeah this is about 1924
and we actually recently found in our
library the popular science magazine
with a cover story on filming this
newsreel oh this is nuts I've seen this
now which windmill is this can anybody
tell there's two windmills in Golden
Gate Park well there will be I think
this is the northern one because of what
you'll see in the background
the northern one or the Dutch windmill
has round sides and the Murphy windmill
has an angled edge
[Music]
and puke
so we're in the park now in 1938-39
the old DeYoung yeah actually 2d Young's
back
and this kind of speaks for itself
it's about youth in San Francisco
[Music]
the golden salmon Cisco I know I live
there on the tower bigger pigeon but I
like it yeah we dig it the most on a
towel oh I can see everything once in a
while I sit back
I'd be the shoes they think they're the
toughest bet on my corner
I'd shimmy shimmy Coco go to the mole
you can always tell plenty ace on every
corner I look too hard fella
they got guards you got a thousand seven
the key tender stuff Sheen the boss
because it's pirate from some honor at
night you can always tell that's the
lonely one
bet you some parts of mission and always
tail thousand in every corner there was
a crane they'd be right on deck for
chestnut
legato man's Academy mic is on this
thing at first sight a fellow then calls
me anything
bad things in a quick getaway thumps
door softly so remember this the Potrero
Center
yeah with seal Stadium before that seal
Stadium before that okay where are we
this is 1939 and it's Visitacion Valley
Visitacion Valley that's my guess I
think this is quite a sweet little movie
and it looks awesome
that's when service stations deserve
their names
yeah I'm guessing this valley and I'm
thinking maybe somewhere over there in
the southeast it looks like yeah I'm
thinking near Bayshore so I think it
might be beige or good call when you
shoot home video shoot the gas stations
and the bar is you know don't do the
don't do the flowers
this is a get a bit loan by star re-do
balls and three balls and one strike
[Music]
sorry again hit them bad luck and hit
apply here we have the players all lined
up after the game they sure did a swell
job but they didn't quite make it
nonetheless in the background you will
see the members and their wives and
friends that were here today to
encourage them in a victory in sight
make it but better boys they're all
excited they're having their pictures
taken but in a short time we all be
together again and ok boys I think this
is it we're just about ready to say
goodbye for the day so signing off for
Argonauts large boys next time you have
to get out and win again these are
loaned by Scott Stark and these are
movies he found in his house the
previous owner had a small film company
this may be a wartime Victory Garden or
it may be immediately post-war it's a
little hard to tell from the codes on
the film
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
strong union
time to go to wild side west for a beer
and they built their addition onto their
house andrey fronted their house in 1947
and so that's when this footage comes
from nice ad in the middle of a
residential neighborhood
there was actually a film lab in that
house as well and this was the view
no diamond heights residential the Sutro
Tower
Oh Sears
do we know where we are deep trouble
yes it's gonna be going to one of the
coastal defense batteries presumably and
this we just found
just by the way is before Kodachrome had
stable dyes
so it's about 1959 and I want you to
watch closely when we see the exercise
yard
so you can actually see inmates
this is just below the cliff house and
Sutro heights it's the edge of Playland
I'm still looking for more Sutro Baths
material you're gonna see every frame
that I have and your job this year is to
find me more Sutro Baths material
this is 1939 that Pierre used to have a
pipe and they would pump the seawater
all the way down to like Larkin Street
for a bath down there the Olympic
saltwater pumping company
they're Mavericks
tourism footage
the pier lasted until like the early 70s
I think part of it started breaking down
and the little pumping station was in
play land and it was there until they
tore Playland down in 72 there's the
surf club that's what the surfers are
these are all covered up now for the
most part
at carousels at your between Gardens now
[Applause]
that's a matter of controversy so plane
land is being demolished
I didn't do this
you take what you can get that's the
pumping station see it says Bush and
Larkin that's right
what real-estate development mostly
wasn't it yeah I think was German yets
Hogan's it was diamond Heights too
that's the friends and relations you
know that building that was a surf club
before it was a place called Topsy's
roost which was sort of a racist [ __ ]
chicken restaurant in the 20s and here's
our four second shot slowed to eight of
the front of the Sutro Baths I want more
and that's the Sutro Baths as well
before they burned down shot from a
blimp
66 burned down they had a fire of the
little buildings between the Cliff House
and Sutro Baths in like 63 but the main
baths burned in 66
it might have been arson it was a money
loser for the owners at the time and it
had already been closed there were plans
to build a big high-rise apartment
building there and before that they're
gonna have a men's club the Pacific
Edgewater hey come on in and sit down
for a while the attendant will use to
call that did you see this adjustable
reading room sort of like a jet oh it
seems more roomy huh
[Applause]
it's an hour
so how come
film is so much more powerful than
stills I mean something that happens
here and you see this stuff moving you
know for me it's the unexpectedness it's
that you don't know what's still you you
see it one moment that it's a
self-contained moment in film you never
quite know what's going to happen what
the twist will be and then another thing
I know the editing is pretty interesting
because you're all over the place now is
that gonna scramble our minds this isn't
sequential in time it isn't sequential
in region exactly it's a little loose
but I never claimed to be an editor but
also you know it it wouldn't profit by
being completely rigidly tied to the map
so I there's a vague you know
neighborhood focus but I did lose it a
little bit this year should we all we
have our stools yeah
I'm noticing myself walking because of
this damn movie you know and you see a
Hollywood film did there's nothing about
walking but people are walking in these
really idiosyncratic way all three
leaders yeah your your sea legs you have
to get your sea legs laughing like
you've been at this how long I started
collecting film about 25 years ago I was
in New York and I was a typesetter
working nights and then my roommates got
money to make a movie and so I got hired
as research director and the movie went
into limbo but I started to collect
material and this went through a number
of incarnations and then about ten years
ago I moved out here and many of you
know our collection went to Library of
Congress but we have continued to
collect and the big focus now is amateur
film local history few other things but
not trying to collect a world anymore so
what happens I mean you've been looking
at this kind of stuff of stills in the
footage in the
fermer and so on over a period of time
and you develop your collector skills
and your creator skills what happens to
your sensitive history in time and in
this case San Francisco when you watch
this stuff that much over that long
period of time right you know it's this
issue that I wouldn't make it as a
scholar conventionally because because
I'm interested in history as its
represented in history as its
experienced and then put back out again
through the minds and the eyes in the
hands of these makers so there's a
certain looseness but on the other hand
they it's loosey-goosey but it's also
tremendously vivid and it's a great I
mean what do you see now they didn't see
the first year or two what kind of
things you're spotting right I mean the
detail is very very interesting I try to
look at the detail very closely but I'm
also interested in what the detail
reveals what the traces reveal who's
hanging out in the periphery what's on
that sign what is that little kid in the
corner actually doing you know it's it's
it's an eye for um that kind of telling
detail yep and also may I say something
else it's yes so it's um when you look
at most conventional historical
documentaries typically somebody writes
a story and then they try to find
pictures and sound to fill it you know
sometimes they even call it eye candy
they're trying to cover a pre-existing
script and I'm really interested in what
arises out of the material I don't like
this
conventional storytelling thing it's
tyrannical it's setting you know
documentary back to insist that you have
to have a conventional narrative arc and
force all the material the material is
its own story so people how many people
are shoot video one way or another with
iPhones and flips and whatnot a lot of
people they're gonna be shooting anyway
some of that stuff's gonna come to you
or your successor what would you prefer
they shoot and not shoot okay no more
fishing
but you know you want the bat you want
the the gas station the restroom in the
gas station I mean you yeah I'd like I
mean you know no flowers no gardens no
unless you know it's unless ya listeners
actually know pans over buildings where
you follow the building line like this
but focus on one of the things that's
great about the the G family films is
that they were just so systematic and
completest about shooting life you know
their own lives in a background against
the city as the places you know they
went to Golden Gate Park there's
wonderful footage of Golden Gate Park so
it's a sense of people within the
landscape and people in a social
environment and that just makes it so
special to look at now what's that well
if the G's would like yeah where's their
hands I don't want to force them there
they are
[Music]
but yeah it's everyday life it's that
stuff that you know you want to think
what was somebody's everyday experience
they went to the gas station they went
to the bar they went shopping that's
what really kind of you know do you
collect stuff in the moment do you
collect stuff from this year from last
year at all only stuff I shoot I don't
collect video very much it's so high so
you shoot I just with my still camera
yeah I shoot video and as an archivist
you find yourself shooting differently
than you would if you were Oh totally
say mostly what do you mean I go to the
airport and I turn my camera on and I
put something kind of next to it so it
doesn't look like I'm shooting and I
shoot 18 minutes of people walking by I
don't know why you know everything looks
beautiful when you see it on the little
glowing rectangle and it just and it I
shoot a lot of sort of record of things
like that I shoot I love I think most of
us love footage that's driving POV shot
out at the front of a car or a train or
a cable car and I shoot a lot of that
yeah that trip down Market Street is
it's amazing astonishing yeah and it was
it's interesting is it builds up stuff
and you're sort of learning how to see
what's there and you know and oh my gosh
there's a guy in a bicycle there's a
horse that and in your point about that
the the free-flowing everybody goes
anywhere a traffic pattern that's we
should have a day
everybody will stay home in San
Francisco yeah we just turned off the
traffic lights work it out people haha
fee attest you could have done that in
the 60 everybody would remember it it's
like the day when the various countries
when they switched from driving on one
side to switching on the other and the
whole country came to a stop and crept
intrepidly across the street stuff like
that yeah isn't that wonderful music on
the sidewalk that was amazing and in the
walking of the bridge that also could be
much more regular than every 50 years
whatever it is that's right really
that right and what happened nobody died
from the traffic probably well this is
this point you know you're right you're
right this is this thing we were talking
about the anymore happened again so well
no it's it's it's nice you know not
necessarily to think of this material as
coming out of antiquity just
representing the past when I look at
historical material I always kind of
think of it as possibly predictive as
well maybe this represents something
that we're going to come back to or it
represents a state or a you know a some
kind of quality of living which which
may happen again in the future
so I don't just buy this rigid boundary
between past present future at all well
it's certainly true I've seen buildings
that you know change over time we saw
some in the market Street there they put
steel there yeah well in the front and
then somebody looks at the old
photograph you know that was better and
then they they recreate the building the
way it used to be and then that beats
back and forth a couple times this film
make people do the same thing I don't
know there's a chance I mean that's
looked like a lot of fun yeah right
we know film influences fashion you know
we know that the China Syndrome caused
put nuclear power in the in the trash
for a number of years films sometimes
have effects like that in this case I
don't know this is you know what are we
gonna make of San Francisco are we gonna
look back and be nostalgic and try to
keep it from changing or are we going to
try to guide its change in an
intelligent way I mean that's the spirit
that I'd love this material to be taken
in you well that's an interesting issue
yes so it's everywhere it turns out you
know um probably in talking about
original film you know rather than
copies of material probably you know
there's a few things I've learned
sometimes I get lucky the the usf
vegetable war and the autogyro landing
on City Hall plaza that came out of a
basement in the Richmond District that I
just happened to ask and there were a
bunch of cans of nitrate film there's
film everywhere you know probably 20
million families shot 8 and 16
millimeter and it's all over the place
after a while it just kind of comes to
you flypaper effect somebody brings you
something do you copy it or do you want
the original and they don't have it
anymore how does that work ideally we
would we would collect the original in
many cases we'll pay to transfer
people's films and we'll have a copy to
work with and they'll get a video copy
as well as getting their films back a
lot of ways like Library of Alexandria
they've you know they went out me and
people ships of all they had they would
not be a pop he's back I was compulsory
you can now sail on with the copies of
the books we just stole yeah but you
know I think this I'm serious about that
we should all be better historians this
is something the barrier to entry is
very low any of us can do this on a
neighborhood level or on a regional
level
well act and redistribute so is
everybody shooting video now it is you
know it's the whole world of archiving
going grassroots or what happens now um
so good point there's a big shift in the
archival world away from the good ideas
are not coming from the big centralized
institutions in DC in New York and LA
that interesting ideas are coming from
the periphery regional and local
archives home movie day many of you may
know about that something that happens
every year in about 70 cities now where
people bring home movies and they
that's shown and some of them make it
into archives and they learn about what
the issues are and people are starting
to think a lot about how to collect
their and preserve their personal
digital materials and I think that's the
next big thing is the net and YouTube
and all that kind of making all of this
more of just a genre that everyone feels
comfortable with yeah I don't know we've
really come to terms with it it happened
have we come to terms with YouTube I
mean it kind of it happened it's there I
don't think we really understand it yet
it may not last long enough for us to
really understand it for one thing it's
probably 200 million videos that aren't
being saved
nobody knows under what conditions
they're being maintained it's the big
archives of our time and yet it isn't in
archives they don't do preservation it's
a collection I think we're gonna come to
this kind of more slowly and and also
what's it what's it gonna mean to have
access to so much I think takes a long
time for these to shake out
for sure it's it's a video access
service it's not an archive in the sense
that it doesn't preserve its material
you know and it doesn't really organize
it in an archival way so it doesn't but
it's an amazing phenomenon you can be
part of it too
if we don't know that YouTube is
permanent Brewster is YouTube's
permanent and things disappear lots of
things disappear from YouTube all the
time yeah I mean we don't need YouTube
to save video there's lots of other ways
that we can collect video and film and
other material and make it available we
can use the Internet Archive there's
many many other services and there's
many archives that can collect physical
material but this is still very much
insurance your point is well-taken
though because now most everybody in the
world thinks that YouTube is what Moving
Image archives are all about and regular
Moving Image archives are never gonna be
able to catch up because there Thunder
has been stolen what's interesting is
YouTube looks like your old movies
they're really low res you don't think
you're stealing anything this is the
great you know on on is this I'm sure
wasn't planned but the low res in
YouTube you know it cleanses you of any
guilt right I mean I think it's I didn't
hear this
I keep it on a couple hard disks and I
usually don't look at it very much
it's just there right I've shared a
little bit of it at the Internet Archive
a lot of it isn't very interesting I
should take the time and share more I'm
not that good a shooter have you done a
home movie night should you we do one
I'd be great to do a home movie night
yeah what's gonna be okay we've got a
century now looking at moving images
basically and I mean the stuff that goes
back a century you're really going you
know I I just have contained a period
longer than most people's lives 100
years from now there's continuity we'll
have 200 years of that kind of content I
mean pretty soon he gets to be like well
let's just go back and look at some of
the video of the SU vias erupting when
it came down over pompeii and
herculaneum boy look at the people run
this stuff changes the relationship
through time it's got who and so we
already have a hundred years of it just
so what's the future of this kind of
access to to the human past I don't
think we know and I don't think we could
put a value on at this boy you know we
could argue that universal access to
everything will turn us into a more
enlightened and historically conscious
people but I'm not willing to argue that
well look at this crowd there's pretty
conscious and enlightened yeah well this
is a great crowd I mean but the reason
you know you don't you can't do this
every day how many of you would be here
if you could do this 52 times a year
like you do so I think it's too early to
tell I don't think we've been able to
address this issue of having you know
incredible simultaneous access to a lot
of and then the fact there's actually we
don't you can't see most TV news
you know it's enclosed it's unless
somebody's grabbed it and put it on
YouTube it's usually not available to
the public you can't see most of the
news reels are held very closely by the
news reel companies for good reasons or
bad reason
to create artificial scarcity they'll
sell you a minute for $3,000 and you can
get in if you're a commercial film
researcher and pay fifty an hour but
most archives are not really accessible
this is tip of the iceberg you know well
it's better than BBC did which erase
their archives because well everybody it
was a race yeah everybody everybody's
erased but most of what's being shot by
the people here is going to be you know
erased or lost or whatever do you care I
think about this you know you go to the
Salvation Army
you're gonna start are you gonna start
seeing flash drives and you know SD
cards instead of VHS tapes so I have
this contrarian attitude you know
although I would never condone like
intentional destruction of Records which
is like which is you know essentially
cultural warfare it can be genocide 'l
i'm not super concerned that everything
won't survive because of this this idea
that history is driven by desire and
that desire is often for what we don't
know what we can't see what we think is
lacking and a lot of the emergent
histories of the past thirty and forty
years have been built on a sense that we
don't know we don't know very much about
african-american history we don't know
very much about labor history history of
immigration has been swept under the rug
and that has caused people to dig deeper
and try to find those documents and so
in a way scarcity and desire drives the
hunt drives investigation and and brings
histories to life so I you know I'm not
a I don't want to destroy things but I
think sometimes when there's a lack of
evidence it has its formative it's I
didn't you mentioned labor and in the
strikes were mostly over by the time I
was paying attention and we were doing
civil rights and other stuff and so to
just revisit in that footage first the
kind of cheerful guys walking in the
streets with their hats mugging for the
camera and then the not so cheerful and
what's weird is the so-called riot it
hasn't changed you know the teargas
launching the running back and forth the
ducking behind
cars the basically street action that
you know that's could have been shot
anytime in Berkeley your various times
it there is some emerging technology
that's a little scarier all the stuff
that paralyzes you or realization and
the audio the sound based weapons so but
yeah there's people here will be
shooting that and we'll have that in and
except that some of it will also then
zap all of the cameras so that it can
that be sir cameras operating news app
cell phone signals can use happen I
don't think Michael name marks written
about zapping cameras with laser
pointers you can yeah one by one right I
guess you do yeah
I think both archivists and users need
to contribute to the context surrounding
you know any kind of archival record by
adding metadata by commenting on it by
identifying things this happens at the
Internet Archive we know if 2000 odd
films online and a lot of people do shot
listing and do interpretation the
railroad buffs explain you know what
engine this is it's pretty cool yeah
train spotting in time is clearly a big
event here but also this is whole
grassroots phenomenon of the meta
phenomenon of tagging Clay Shirky gave a
talk in this series a while back and who
said who knew that cats and sinks was a
category yeah again you know I'm very
hesitant about eternal izing the present
because the practice of three to five
years you know on a rapid changing media
and the web it's it doesn't tell us a
lot doesn't give us a lot to chew on
about how we're gonna be relating to
information down the road but we are in
a position to set some powerful examples
now and you know any of you can download
San Francisco footage off the Internet
Archive and cue your own curate your own
show quite a lot of this material is
online there's all sorts of
possibilities this isn't as I say the
barrier to entry is not high and I hope
you will should we do this next year
[Music]
do you have enough new stuff will young
people send you enough things it's up to
you you know this is a Tinkerbell me
yeah it's up to you I I'm beginning to
feel that I have no choice but uh but it
is fun and I'm I'm delighted that so
many of you turned out I loved hearing
what you had to say - it was a this kind
of this notion of the audience making
the soundtrack we should see a lot more
of that we should hear a lot more of
that yeah thank you we'll do it again
thank you happy weird
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you